hello everybody hello today's video is
sponsored by Squarespace calm where you
can get your domain online store or
website made if you're looking to get a
website made they have really beautiful
and dope looking templates where you
could do it all yourself in your website
will end up looking unique and custom
there's nothing to install patch or
upgrade it's all in one and if you have
another website you could bring it on
over to Squarespace because they do
third-party domain transfers regardless
of where your website is right now it
could bundle everything the building
settings everything into one place and
when you're actually ready to make a
purchase for a website or domain type in
Squarespace calm / just kidding news for
10% off and now enjoy this video in
doomed generation news submitted by
David so and Joe are couple goals more
YouTube beef is rising up between cash
me outside and wove icky along with a
nine year old girl I [ __ ] saw this
[ __ ] little Tay
yeah I saw this you know we should even
promote this [ __ ] dude we cash mail side
and no wall Vicky are they gonna fight
no no Mickey remember wall dick yeah I
want to see a boxing match
this is Danielle catch me outside girl
she's [ __ ] 15 my baby or whatever
she's 15 yet she's the one that claims
she's black remember she's 18 they're
both cute I think I like this because
they're both trash so I want to see the
trash of YouTube fight that [ __ ] is
killed thank you
you think she's cute there are some
photos or she knows like she knows how
to make herself she is not cute dude
she's the chef a friendship bracelet
around her waist what is that friendship
she's cute I don't know things and then
this is little tape
right no no you think about now she's
cute like to me it's like a little
two-year-old around their moms right
like money and cards nine oh no she
talked stuff like she's like she's more
the [ __ ] kitchen
that's like Isaac holding their your mom
your wallet look it's you agent
she looks Asian think so I can't tell I
don't know I was trying to shoot like
Cambodia should I find out more info on
these little girls but on the articles
I've read it's just everyone's saying
like this girl just came out of nowhere
and she has like so many followers let's
talk about what she looks crazy like
she's using it as a phone like yeah she
got more money than I do no she does I
don't she's ball and do didn't she she's
friends with like [ __ ] all these
rappers and [ __ ] you keep her something
she has 15 posts and 800,000 followers
yeah 15 post
alright we're teaching Takahata cus
we're teaching them how to cuss we're
gonna pull out our savings and he's
gonna be doing much hurt mom runs her
cuz I really couldn't find anything on
this little girl well go on her
Instagram and then it says account ran
by my mom or whatever managed by miranda
cosgrove
no that's that's fake Oh cuz they asked
her if if she if Miranda runs it and and
they're like nah it doesn't say anywhere
that her mom runs it just account
managed by we ran across under cosgrove
well that's a screenshot right with that
no this came all recently whoa Vicki and
bad baby Danielle
they ended up getting into an
altercation like in person or online
person I'm sure you guys in Glendale
what is it bad baby or a bad Bob Bobby I
mean she spelled it that way but it
supposed to be bad I thought it was bad
Barbie yeah but it's bad baby pushes
from Boston or something yeah from
Australia bad they don't so here we go
why does she look like a [ __ ] Arizona
iced tea green tea thing
oh that's talkin bad baby cool with a
vigor but she can't do [ __ ] she ain't
even punch right baseship [ __ ] like for
sure hey you a [ __ ] little stupid [ __ ]
that compañía my sister
yeah Beach go back to beam up your mom
on dr. Phil little girls talking like
that or 18 year-olds hanging out with
Emmanuel
I think cash knows I did call that
girl's bluff cuz the minute she stepped
her she's like what yeah what so you
know she's not really down she's not you
can tell if someone calls you out and
you're like what what what and this she
didn't act hard until the body heart
step exactly you know that she's a
little [ __ ] dude then later she comes
out Vicki comes out saying like well you
know I'm 18 now I don't want her
coming to me and [ __ ] so I'm not gonna
sued if your hood you don't even give a
[ __ ] about age you don't give a [ __ ]
about the line you'll [ __ ] about any of
that sure not hurt that girl little
nine-year-old literally walks around
with a stack of cash the funny thing is
that's [ __ ] how did this all start cuz
I was just trying to figure out that I
didn't know how how it started I just
saw the video where they got into a
little fight and then they're talking
[ __ ] and I'm just laughing at all the
[ __ ] talking well Danielle saying that
Vicki who's that Neil catch me outside
so she said that Vicki called her
Danielle's friend like a derogatory term
at some party and then that's the reason
why she got so close she called it
weirdo information makes my brain melt I
know even the kids are interests I think
it's tight I want to see a boxing match
come out of this yeah I like it cuz it's
the new YouTube they never lost the
boxer was the fight you know women
should be proud like this is next-level
[ __ ] now it's like women starting fights
and inequality she's a nine-year-old
grown-ass woman they give themselves
these little nicknames they just look
like Pokemon to me oh we got wove icky
she's like that on my personality peeve
is like whoa she says wow I mean that
nine-year-old still a nine year old
because like when they were yelling that
little girl looks scared yeah she look
she look really scared no but she's hard
though what are the parents do I know
they like I like the pink pages working
at some high-rise office job you know
what's genius if the parent is
orchestrating all this [ __ ] goes alright
this is what you're gonna say and yeah
like this entire beef between the two of
them orange is just Orchestrator to get
like more drama toilet go back to
[ __ ] dr. Phil beat your mama oh my
god that lion was amazing I was
especially coming from a nine year old
I'm like Dan you clever that's dope
that's hilarious I'm such a pretty smart
she's actually pretty smart to have a
line
yeah cuz I think if I was nine and I and
I had to vlog and say some [ __ ] on his
blade your robber I'd glue [ __ ] yeah you
don't know if she copied it from a movie
or from my good video then I'm not even
smart up to copy at all I remember like
just picking lines from like my favorite
movies that I thought were really smart
yeah and then I would say oh and I felt
like so cool because they didn't know
where I got it from but when I was 9
when I watch movies I ignore the
dialogues I don't know what the hell
they're talking about
I twice how you watch a movie that's how
dumb I was yeah I remember when you're
kid you're like there's too much talking
yeah you never heard that when people
are like there's too much talking like
what the [ __ ] are they talking so much
like I hate it it's too much this movie
has too much talking when I was watching
like three ninjas right there's a scene
I just like the jokes right so like
there's the scene where the bullies is
like losers say what or something like
that and then the kids like what and
like haha laughs any like made his crew
laugh at his jokes and I thought that
was so funny and you see what that's
what he's saying that goes back to his
point when he was nine he didn't even
know that that was clever but you
thought that was clever but not really
smarter than me now that you repeat it
here though it sounds dumb as [ __ ] it
does so notice that little girl like
that she was clever she's actually smart
smart kiddo to do that even if she
copied she copied the clever [ __ ] like
even adults will be saying oh you're
saying that I didn't copy the clever
[ __ ] yeah yeah yeah you're not making a
correct comparison because you're
comparing yourself as a nine year old
when you had nothing you know I mean the
Internet is there now so yeah now these
kids are growing up so much faster
that's not uncommon they don't have a
nine year olds or that intelligent where
they can tell jokes at adult people and
they just spoke a joke that adults
thought were humorous yeah but I think
you're giving people too much credit
it's like when people call Kim
Kardashian a genius you know what I mean
like you have to think about climate and
what people what kids are ingesting and
and looking at nowadays we weren't we
just had cartoons and dumb [ __ ] yeah so
obviously that was like our level of
intelligence because nine year olds can
do full face of beautiful makeup now and
like we didn't
they're pearls we have these tutorials
boy who is a freakin genius at makeup
yeah and he's nine yeah yeah but they
have all these resources like well if
you put it like this - like I guarantee
you like if you put a math problem front
of you as a 9 yo and you put in front of
her she negotiate all got smashed oh
it's all relative true I know I see I'll
speak English I know numbers this
article I found out I the 9 year old
little tape and I immediately thought of
Isaac like [ __ ] my kids 10 and he's like
nowhere near like this world obviously
she's in a completely different what
grade is nine fourth grade what's great
no well I think is it fourth cuz I got
fourth or fifth he's 10 well it depends
on when your birthday is true in January
sir
okay older kids so 910 can also be 5th
grade 1011 can also be bit yeah oh you
know what by that time I was pretty
[ __ ] corrupt 4th grade were 30 I
think a rat's when I started learning
bad boys that's when I started yeah
before that it was all innocent and in
like I remember we had your momma jokes
it [ __ ] like that and those got pretty
bad yeah they're pretty funny no no but
like this little girl just influenced by
I don't know I wasn't sure if it was a
little boy or little girl why I'd rather
have her be hard like be hard like that
then starting to show off like she's
still trying to do the sexy [ __ ] nice
ass pose but she's not oh is that what
she was doing yeah I thought she was
like licking my star - at least she's
not just like that you don't leave that
oh I'll give it to her and she shouldn't
be down our hair either what the [ __ ]
why you messing up your hair already
girl oh yeah didn't even think of that
that's true that's a good bookie what's
the problem though oh she's involved in
this somehow I mean I don't know I guess
because she's friends with Vicki like
she was there with the wolf but she was
talking [ __ ] in the video no yeah so
like she's speaking out of age is that
the no no I guess my thing is like isn't
that between wove ik and whatever she's
just jumping in is that is that what the
problem is to my knowledge yes okay
that's that seems to what is happening
here she won't Vicki's a homegirl that's
why so she's like she got her back yeah
it's some
like that have you guys seen this clip
that's been going around we're just guys
on a radio station he goes my home is if
I shoot someone don't shoot someone if I
go kill someone I'll go kill someone
it'll my home is what well my home's
always got my back if I die he dies and
the guys saying that so the whole time
was I kill someone kill someone and then
when he says when I die he dies he's
like if I get rid he's right if I suck a
dick he's so addicted I don't think it
was that far off from these girls at my
8 at the same age and I hung out with
people like oh [ __ ] but it's just we
didn't have any cameras to have the
internet yeah all the stupid [ __ ] never
got with 18 year old as us as a 8 year
old no I mean I was hanging out with 18
year olds when I was 13 yeah yeah 13
that makes sense though because you're
trying to be incepted into a crew and
your buddy in high school to get in we
don't know she's a tag-along because her
sister or brothers cool with them or
whatever cuz that would happen sometimes
too like we would go to the park and
then they're like you know
you know like five what accident was
that Indonesia
[Music]